no what's up how we doing hey doing good
john how are you
outstanding so how can i help brother
yeah
so with kind of christmas time coming up
all the christmas parties going on
um i guess my wife and i are kind of
curious on how to navigate
um hey hold on hold on one second can
you do me a huge favor
yeah how old are you noah uh 25 25. all
right i'm gonna give you some
world advice that has nothing to do with
why you're calling is that cool
yes in the first sentence if you go back
and listen to this on the podcast
you said the word kinda twice
and i think sorta or probably or
something like that
like so with kind of christmas kind of
coming around and me and my wife kind of
work
i want you to be 25 year old freaking
noah
and start speaking with periods at the
end of your sentences the world needs
you okay
yes sir all right let's do it again here
we go ready go
all right so uh how do we navigate
christmas parties
with christmas coming around the corner
with my mom's side specifically
uh who my wife and i don't necessarily
connect with all that much
um so how do we kind of navigate or
excuse me how do you know there you
uh navigate those parties um especially
when we can't really use
the the covid uh scenario next year you
know do we bring that up with them i
guess i'm just looking for guidance on
what to do i love it man all right so no
this is a question that's going to help
millions and millions of people so thank
you for
having the courage to call and ask um
there's so many folks going through this
so many folks navigated thanksgiving
either well
or poorly or sort of e right
and now you're in it
and so thank you for calling so let's do
it i want to do a
mind experiment okay okay so
it's your mom's side of the family is
that right correct how long you've been
married
uh last july it's a year and a half oh
it's a year and a half you all
y'all are figuring this out as you go
right correct yeah i love it
traditions so your mom says hey all of
us are getting together
at such and such event and you say
we're not going to be able to make it
thank you so much for the invitation
hope you'll have an awesome time
period what's what's your mom's response
um so i mean wait
so we right before this uh phone call is
this weekend we did uh
we did message them we said hey you know
just with everything going on
uh we that was exactly what i actually
said you know hey thanks for the invite
hope you guys have a blast we're just
not gonna make it this year
uh and this year you know what she said
okay you know sorry not to see you this
year but
we understand and it was you know
that it was an easy transition but
again kind of so do you feel weird about
saying that
i mean a little i guess the background
is growing up
you know we uh i felt obligated
to kind of go to the excuse me to go to
the uh party
yep um on my mom's side especially with
my dad's side
uh it's always a blast so i never have
any issues there just with
especially my mom's it would always be
kind of the extended family so her
cousins her aunts and uncles like the
whole shebang
um of recent years it's it's just her
immediate family so her sisters and then
my grandma
why don't you like go into why don't you
like going do they hug you and kiss you
and tell you how wonderful you are
talk politics like why don't you like to
go no
just i guess awkward
um besides those family christmases
i honestly never really hang out with my
mom's side you know
never hanging out just out of out of
that
holiday but dig in to dig into awkward
for me
mm-hmm what does that mean it means
you're just standing there eating
listening to stories
you've heard 30 times and and being
around a bunch of
middle-aged or older women what's
awkward about it
yeah i guess with uh
i don't know um because here's the thing
if it's just awkward noah then go
like go it's an evening that you are
honoring your mom
and her family with and you're
25 you're gonna bring joy to them
they're gonna be excited to see you
you're the handsome little boy that made
well and here's his beautiful new wife
yeah it's boring life is boring right
it's awkward but if you if it's
something
put it this way if y'all just gonna sit
home and watch netflix and that's gonna
be more exciting
then forget that dude go if there's a
reason y'all aren't safe
if they make your wife feel
uncomfortable if
it's just not as ex i mean go right so
you're not giving me you're not selling
me on why
why your mom and her family aren't worth
a few hours of your evening
yeah is it because it's just not fun
um i well with i guess the
the awkwardness behind it it's it's not
necessarily fun with us in the sense
that
even with the extended family one it was
typically just my brothers and i
uh just just uh at the table you know
talking with each other and kind of
saying hi you know for that few minutes
and then doing our own thing the rest of
the hour and a half two hours so i guess
that's kind of part of it
so no no listen i want you to do
something this year
if it's safe medically
i want you to go and i want you and your
wife to plan to ask
your mom questions her sister questions
so here's the thing
you're showing up to this event
really expecting to be entertained and
i want you to go to be a participant
go to be somebody who isn't waiting to
be plugged into but who's plugging into
other people
and my promise is those folks who are
there who are older than you who are
twice your age or 15 years older than
you or however old they are
have stories to tell that would blow
your mind have fun adventures to talk
about
if you can poke through man my
grandmother was as proper as propper
could be
but if you could get behind that proper
dude she was a riot
like she was the most sarcastic awesome
hilarious
biting just a riot but she had to get
past it right
i want you to go and think of it this
way i'm going on behalf of my mom not
for me and dude you're talking like a
few hours brother
that's not a lot
i don't i i don't man when this call
started i thought it was
you weren't safe they made you'll feel
uncomfortable if it's just
boring dude because they're gonna
they're gonna not be there
they're gonna not be there someday and i
know you think it doesn't matter i don't
even think it
it i don't care that we don't talk that
much i'm telling you right now when it
comes to legacy it's going to matter
my wife is a qualitative researcher she
goes through stories
and letters and for the last few years
she's been
working on some
several books but these books are based
on letters that she's found and
interviews she's had with
90 year old 95 year old
members of her family she's tracked them
down she's met with them in strange
towns and little coffee shops and
nursing homes all across the united
states
and those boring quiet people who just
sit there in the corner at family events
have wild stories in her case
family members who were chased by nazis
in germany
and who had to figure out how to run a
dairy farm and had to figure out how to
survive the dust bowl
and who had to figure out how to how to
eat cows but they didn't know what they
were doing i mean i had to figure stuff
out
and you just get into those stories and
you find these love letters and you find
this richness in depth
my brother your family's not there to
entertain you your family's there to be
honored
to be with right and so if you're
safe if they're safe now again this is
weird because of covid
but if you're safe they're safe i want
you to go and i want you to you and your
wife to have fun
with coming up with questions that
you're going to ask what's the best
boyfriend you ever had
what was your first kiss what was the
weirdest date you ever went on
aunt whoever aunt karen aunt becky who
whoever they are
hey grandma what is your favorite
boyfriend besides granddad
like right i want you to dig into these
questions
ask them what their favorite songs were
could they dance do they know who chubby
checkers was and do they love him right
get into it and my hope is you're going
to find out
a richness and depth to your family to
your legacy
here's the thing in and noah this isn't
i'm not i'm not harping on you now
brother
we live in this culture where we burn
grandma's house down just because it was
old it's a small
3-2 made out of old hardwood
and we just burn it down because it's
too little and we throw up too tall and
skinnies they're going to last for about
25 years before they fall apart
so we can maximize the square footage of
that of that dirt
both presidential candidates were thrown
out because they were old
right that was the most common criticism
they both were whining
a lot and they were old and man
sometimes behind that elder
statesmanship
is a lot of wisdom they've seen a lot of
things
i want to challenge all young people
listening to this if you're under the
age of 40
i want you to make it your mission in
life to surround yourself people who are
older than you
and not think about um is this boring
is this awkward no man think about what
you can glean what kind of wisdom you
can pick up
how you can be with folks and that might
mean getting around folks at your church
that might mean connecting with family
during the holidays and let's be super
honest this year it may not happen
kova is just screwing up everything
right and
elderly folks are in a very high risk
category so may not work
but man put yourself in those situations
so noah go do it
get around them um
in fact i want you to do it i want you
to call me back and if i was wrong i
will announce to the whole united states
and the world i was screwed up and i was
wrong no issue to stay at home
and then you'll find out and the next
year you'll be 26 your marriage will be
two and a half years old
and y'all will know we are never going
again